[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight here's a helpful hint about how
your government works we're full of
helpful hints on the show if you ever
seek consensus forming in Washington run
something awful is about to happen for
decades you'll remember there was total
consensus that our trade deals could not
be better
they helped everyone meanwhile as they
were telling us that America's
manufacturing sector died in huge parts
of the middle class died along with it
then it was bipartisan consensus on the
Iraq war and the stockpiles of weapons
of mass destruction would supposedly
find there but didn't fears later there
was consensus on banking regulations
that was just before the financial
crisis hit though there was still more
consensus on the creation of an
all-seeing surveillance state that was
supposed to somehow help you but that is
now scanning your face and reading your
texts there wasn't much debate in
Washington about any of those policies
there should have been so it's with some
skepticism that we note a new consensus
forming here
this one about our southern border it
may look bad down there they're telling
us but calm down it's fine everything's
just fine that's the new word from max
boot boot is a columnist for Jeff Bezos
his newspaper but more than that boot is
the living repository of every
warmed-over cliche every silly
half-truth every stale scrap of stupid
conventional wisdom the buffoons who run
this place have thought up recently so
here's the latest this is from boots
appearance on CNN last night I'm ready
to declare a national emergency the
national emergency is not on the
southern border it's in Washington DC
with a president who is lawless and out
of control who is this guy
well max boot calls himself a foreign
policy expert that's a title that
doesn't actually mean anything but in
practice it allows boot to agitate for
more counterproductive foreign wars in
the years since 9/11 max boot has
demanded military intervention in
Afghanistan Iraq Syria Libya Iran and
North Korea and likely many other places
he's called for the u.s. to topple the
Saudi monarchy and of course like so
many neo-cons boo
fell headlong into the Russia conspiracy
nuttiness for more than two excruciating
years it's hard to think of anyone in
this country more discredited than max
boot going to him for foreign policy
advices like giving Jeffrey Dahmer a
cooking show he'd be the last person you
would ask so of course max boot now has
gigs at CNN The Washington Post and the
Council on Foreign Relations because
that's how Washington really works the
key is never apologized
never admit fault no matter what watch
max boot explain that the idea of
toppling the Libyan government which was
deranged was in fact brilliant we just
didn't do it right we did a great job of
overthrowing Gadhafi but did nothing to
secure the country afterwards and there
was I might add a similar lack of
planning for our pullout in the case of
Iraq where there was very little sense
of what would happen after US troops
left and in 2010 we can't think about
these as being kind of quick in-and-out
engagements we send some troops kill
some people and then come back home to a
victory parade sadly it doesn't work
that way buuut didn't explain how
exactly it does work he didn't need to
explain
everyone knows his assumption it's the
same as permanent Washington's core
assumption military occupation is always
the right answer no matter what the
question is sending somebody else's kids
to a foreign country is always in
everywhere the right thing to do when
Donald Trump pledged to pull Americans
out of Syria max boot went crazy just on
principle because no troops can ever
leave ever there is nobody who knows
anything about the situation in Syria
who recommends doing this this is a
Christmas gift to America's enemies this
will help Isis this will help Russia
this will help Iran this will help
Bashar Assad and this will hurt Israel
and our Kurdish allies what a max boot
not say what do you notice about that
well he never explained how keeping
Americans in Syria would help the United
States why didn't he mention because he
doesn't care nobody in Washington cares
and maybe that's why you never hear
anyone ask questions about our current
military commitments are we overextended
perhaps well here the numbers as of
tonight we have nearly a hundred and
seventy-five thousand active-duty
personnel serving
overseas American troops are posted in a
hundred and fifty-eight different
countries for perspective there are only
a hundred and ninety five countries
total on the entire planet we're almost
everywhere this map might give you a
sense of the scale of it keep in mind
there is no world war currently in
progress this is what we've signed up
for in peacetime and yet you may notice
that there is one place American troops
are not they are not on our southern
border protecting us they should be we
could use them tens of millions of
illegal immigrants already live here in
the United States we don't know the
exact number we don't even know who they
are they just show up and a hundred
thousand more are showing up every month
over time this is how countries collapse
max boot doesn't think that's a crisis
nobody in Washington thinks it's a
crisis as far as they're concerned
illegal immigration is just some right
wing talking point that Trump throws to
his base at rallies and Grand Rapids you
know what they think is a crisis you
know they're really concerned about
medical care in Morocco that's a problem
we must solve immediately luckily we
have exercise African lion never heard
of it you're paying for it in the last
year eleven hundred US military
personnel have participated in that
exercise all of them working to make
Morocco healthier how about the plight
of the Ethiopian Navy Ethiopian Navy
needs a lot of help considering that
Ethiopia is entirely landlocked as a
country thank heaven for our Sixth Fleet
they're on it the Navy just said in a
press release last week bragging about
new talks with the Ethiopian government
to quote discuss the exciting task of
building the Ethiopian Navy feel safer
the people of Mozambique feel safer US
military aircraft have flown 60 missions
they transported more than six hundred
sixty three hundred metric tons of
relief supplies in there in the wake of
a cyclone that was nice
in Honduras we currently have four
hundred American troops stationed our
612 air base squadron recently helped
extinguish a wildfire in a small city
called Co myoga in Malaysia meanwhile a
u.s. Navy amphibious Construction
Battalion is rebuilding water tanks at
an elementary school and we can go on
and on now these are all good
works virtuous things done at taxpayer
expense by the most altruistic country
in the history of the world that's us
the United States but what about us what
about our country we're being invaded no
offense to the Ethiopian Navy but we
could use American troops a lot closer
to Tijuana than the Horn of Africa
max Boone and his friend Scott with his
troops on our own border protecting our
own people that's disgusting immoral
it's fascism only in Washington do
people believe that